-- BAD.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY ANNOUNCING THAT BORDER
RESTS EXCEEDED 50,000 FOR THE
THIRD MONTH IN A ROW.
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA WITH US THE
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLER AND
FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT GERALDO
RIVERA.
THIS IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAX.
THEY ARE SAYING DON'T TELL
ANYBODY, WE WANT TO IMPEACH THE
PLAYER.
BUT DON'T SAY IT.
MAXINE WATERS STOP.
YOU HEARD WHAT NANCY PELOSI SAID
ABOUT MS-13 AND THEY WANT TO
KEEP OBAMACARE.
DON'T YOU THINK THOSE WILL BE
BIG ISSUES IN THE NOVEMBER?
>> I THINK THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE
IS THE HOT BUTTON ISSUE IN
NOVEMBER.
THAT WILL BE THE ONE THAT
RESONATES AND SEPARATES THE
PARTIES.
I HAVE A CAUTIONARY NOTE.
I AM A REPUBLICAN AND I DON'T
WANT A DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY.
I THINK THEY WILL ENDEAVOR TO
IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT, OUR
FRIEND WHO IS DOING A TERRIFIC
JOB.
HERE'S MY CAUTIONARY NOTE.
WHEN YOU USE WORDS LIKE ANIMAL
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL YOU ARE
REFERRING TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THESE GANG MEMBERS AND NOT PAINT
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY WITH A
BROAD BRUSH.
WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO PROTECT OUR
BORDERS AND THE RIGHT TO HARD
POLICEWORK IN ANY KIND OF EFFORT
THAT IS LEGAL.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE THE MORAL
RIGHT TO SEPARATE MIGRATING
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS.
I DON'T WANT US TO LOSE THIS
ISSUE BY DOING SOMETHING THAT IS
SO --
>> Sean: OKAY, A WALL WITH A
DOOR.
YOU ARE OKAY WITH THAT?
>> I AM OKAY WITH THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE WALL ON
THE ONE SIDE AND THE DREAMERS
GIVEN A PASS, A GREEN LIGHT.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT OFFERED
THAT AND THE DEMOCRATS DID NOT
TAKE THAT.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> Sean: DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA, AM
I RIGHT ON THE 4 BIG ISSUES OF
2018?
>> OH, I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR.
NOTHING HAS REALLY CHANGED
EXCEPT THE PRESIDENT DELIVERED
ON THESE KEY ISSUES.
HE STARTED TO BUILD THE WALL.
THE FIGURES FROM THE DHS ARE
STUNNING.
IT'S THE ECONOMY AND THE
NATIONAL SECURITY AGAIN.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE DEMS
DON'T HAVE A MESSAGE.
THEY ARE WHISPERING IN THE
BACKGROUND ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
WHO IS THEIR REAL LEADER?
>> Sean: THEY WANT HIGHER TACKS
AND IMPEACH PRERMENT.
>> MORE JOBS FOR MS-13.
IT'S A MESSAGE THAT IS INSANITY.
IT'S TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
WHEN NANCY PELOSI SAYS NATIONAL
JOB FIGURES MEAN LITTLE.
THE FIRST TIME EVER WE HAVE FULL
EMPLOYMENT.
YOU HAVE MORE JOBS AVAILABLE
THAN PEOPLE LOOKING FOR JOBS.
NANCY PELOSI, DO YOU WANT MORE
UNEMPLOYMENT?
>> Sean: SHE WANTS TO TAKE THE
CRUMBS BACK.
NO THANK YOU.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OUR HISTORY, WE HAVE MORE JOBS
THAN PEOPLE WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED.
FIRST LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
HISPANIC AMERICANS,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND WOMEN.
>> DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA HITS A
GOOD POINT, SEAN.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS DIVIDED
SOCIETY IS THAT WE ARE NOT ON
THE SAME TEAM.
WE CHEER AGAINST OUR PRESIDENT'S
SUCCESSES.
>> Sean: THE DEMOCRATS DO.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE CHEERING FOR
AMERICA TO FAIL.
THEY CAN'T STAND HIS SUCCESS
BECAUSE IT HURTS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN POWER.
THAT'S A FACT.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE NORTH KOREA
NEGOTIATIONS, I WANT EVERYBODY
TO BE ON THE SAME TEAM.
CHEERING FOR SUCCESS FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> LOOK, THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT AMERICA TO SUCCEED.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE AND
THAT'S WHY THEY WANT TO SABOTAGE